it could reduce pollution
and cut congestion but charging to use
roads would be very unpopular with many
drivers
especially in places where public
transport is patchy
like here in dudley where the nearest
train station is two miles from the town
centre
cannot drive every day basically so i
rely on my car so for them to charge us
for driving
on the roads it's just another extra
charge like insurance which is sky i
anyway
then you've got road text which is
pretty high as well the roads aren't bad
enough as it is never mind
helping to pay the government they need
to fix the roads not pay the government
charges would be introduced to make up
for lost
tax revenue as more people drive
electric cars
with sales of new petrol and diesel cars
to be banned as early as 2030
current motoring taxes raised 40 billion
pounds a year
fuel duty charged at 57.95 pence the
lita on petrol and diesel raises around
28 billion pounds for the treasury
that will eventually disappear road
charging has been suggested by previous
governments only to be scrapped after a
backlash from drivers
well i think to make it more palatable
you have to give some benefits to
drivers so
we have a system every driver would get
3 000
free miles if you live in a rural area
you'd get an
additional 1000 miles then after you've
used up that quota there would be a
charge per mile
there's already a congestion charge in
london and drivers have to pay to use
the
m6 toll in the midlands it's a fixed
charge no matter how far you've driven
on the motorway a new more widespread
system would have to be more
sophisticated
possibly using some form of vehicle
tracking
even those who believe charging is
essential
say it has to be done fairly that means
bringing it in in coordination with
improvements to public transport walking
and cycling
and varying the level of road user
charging
so that it is higher where there are
lots of options
and lower where there are not very good
options
more roads like this could be the price
drivers have to pay
on the way to a greener future becky
johnson sky news